like if Trump can't be on Twitter then
other there's so many other people that
shouldn't be on Twitter here's what I
think about Elon Musk buying Twitter
[Music]
Elon is going to buy Twitter after all
he is oh I didn't know this all right
thoughts should he let Trump back on
does it matter does anything matter
here's what I think about Elon Musk
buying Twitter
okay that's my take on okay why though
because I do who the [ __ ] [ __ ] cares
who owns Twitter right right Elon Musk
just happens to be able to make a story
or [ __ ] get all of a ton of attention
about whatever dude you gotta let if
Twitter already is a [ __ ] Cesspool
you gotta let everybody on it if you're
gonna let anybody on it or make actual
strict rules where people like if Trump
can't be on Twitter then other there's
so many other people that shouldn't be
on Twitter that's the thing it's like if
there's going to be a rule make it for
[ __ ] everybody even the [ __ ] even
people who aren't Donald Trump like
that's the thing the hippocrite the
hippocracy the hypocrisy about Twitter
is that it definitely leans left and it
does extremely
um but it is a private company that's
just not no no I know that I know that
but so if there's some liberals own it
and they're like we don't want [ __ ]
right-wing [ __ ] on it then that's
their prerogative I know that I know
that I do know that but right now it's
bigger than than just a company it's the
way the world runs so it's changing I
know but you can't just have an
exception for it's like this I know this
I know that you can't have just one
company be like no no you can't do that
but every other company can do whatever
the [ __ ] they want I know that but I
think that this is what you're asking if
if Elon should buy it if he's gonna buy
it what he should do and this is what
you should do if you have a big company
like this I think it's your
responsibility to make rules and make
sure everybody abides by it that's it
because Trump got kicked off for [ __ ]
that people are doing all the time every
day he's already said he's gonna let
Trump back on and right I think about
the whole [ __ ] thing all right cool
so there's the advice my advice for Elon
is just [ __ ] keep everybody uh with
the same rules
hello
hello hello hello
[Music]